Us humans are like ships, lost in the ocean
of life.
We seek stable land and hope for guidance
from the ocean’s current, only to have it
carry us on its own uncertain course.
This often brings us towards feelings of helplessness
and confusion, and causes us to desire to
give up control as the captain of our ship.
We look for someone or something to give us
a break from the difficulty of navigating.
This relief often comes in the form of intoxicating
substances.
Intoxicating substances allude to being worthy
captains of our ship, but their destination
is often limited to the shores of their own
abuse.
The greatest hardship of life is life itself.
We are in constant battle against its complexities
and illusions.
When we don’t take the necessary steps to
deal with such complexities and illusions,
we are forced to dwell on them.
Dwelling on the difficulties of life forms
knots in the wiring of our brain.
Just like a knot in a muscle, these knots
restrict our range of mental motion and inhibit
a healthy operation of life.
In our efforts to loosen and alleviate these
knots, we often find our self at the foot
of intoxicating substances.
But the end of the rope that they pull usually
only further tightens them.
Humans are one of the only creatures on planet
earth to purposely form habit out of altering
their own brain.
This is likely a product of the complex maze
that exists between our self and the world.
And drugs create an illusion of smoothness.
Using pleasure-stimulating and mind altering
substances is not always harmful.
But the problem is our inability to understand
how to sometimes create this same smoothness
in life on our own.
It is this that causes the misuse and overuse
of intoxicating substances and it is this
that we must be concerned about.
People are not accomplices to the crime of
drug abuse.
People are victims of life’s complexity
and mortality, and drugs are merely a byproduct.
A person who is fulfilled, need not form habit
out of leaving their mind.
And as a culture, we must understand and be
compassionate towards this.
In order to understand how to appropriately
handle substance abuse problems, we must first
make sure we are appropriately handling human
ones.